[Musique]
bonjour alors je crois qu'il ya pas trop
de surprise sur le fait que je sorte une
analyse non verbale du débat du second
tour entre emmanuelle matheron et marine
le pen en plus c'est pas comme si vous
ne l'aviez pas demandée par tous un
exemple de quelques tweets par exemple
voilà on va entrer directement dans le
vif du sujet cette fois ci j'ai vu le
débat en direct c'est souvent pas le cas
là j'ai pu le voir en direct j'ai pas
pris de notes mais j'ai vu qu'ils
avaient quand même pas mal de choses à
dire il y avait pas mal de choses à dire
sur le non verbal sur le para verbal sur
le verbal sur l'argumentaire sur la
rhétorique évidemment il ya plein de
gens qui vont faire ça très bien de
faire sur la rhétorique sur le fond et
c'est donc moi je vais pas m'y
intéresser on va faire une vidéo full
non verbale du début à la fin donc me
dites pas après ouais mais tu as pas
parler de sita pas parler de comment il
a dit ça parce que ça allait en
contradiction avec ça ce sera pas mon
travail pour cette vidéo on va faire que
le non verbal et en parlant du
non-verbal ça mérite évidemment un petit
disque et meurt sur la manière de faire
comme je le fais à chaque fois eh bien
je vais pas forcément le refaire on va
vous mettre un ancien disc les moeurs et
avec le thème comme vous pourrez le
passé si vous l'avez déjà vu sinon
n'hésitez pas à le regarder je danse et
vidéo analyse je donne pas un avis sur
la personne ou sur le sujet en question
en fait je vais aller piocher dans
pleins beatty de rhétorique de non
verbal de parra verbal dont certains
outils qui sont considérés par certains
comme étant des pseudosciences ce que je
vais dire ça va pas être une vérité ça
va être ma vérité à moi mon analyse
subjective en utilisant tous ces outils
là et en essayant de faire au mieux mais
ce n'est pas une vérité absolue à la fin
ce n'est que la vérité de moi à ce
moment là et j'essaie de ne pas prendre
parti sur les débats en cours de sujets
que j'analyse donc voila en gros je ne
suis ni contrôle ni pro raul quand je
fais ce genre d'exercice je vais essayer
d'être le plus objectif possible mais
c'est subjectif pour les raisons que
vous avez compris alors qu'est ce qu'on
a à dire sur les attitudes sur la
manière de faire sur les regards sur les
postures ben on lance tout ça il y en a
pour quatre heures
dans le monde mais le plus grand atout
de la france c'est son peuple marine le
pen oserais-je alors que le débat à
peine commencées les internautes juste
pour vous que votre adversaire emmanuel
macron je veux démarrer avant même que
je vais célébrer sa musique ne pouvait
sur crédit vous sera remis aux gens n'a
pas enlevé les on a enlevé les seconds
j'en suis absolument en avril on était à
dire alors c'est marrant marine le pen
elle a commencé par un faux départ
est-ce que c'était calculé ou pas je ne
sais pas on va voir tout ça parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est la grande question
qui va se poser dans cette analyse
qu'est ce qui est voulu et qu'est ce qui
n'est pas voulu n'oubliez jamais que le
débat du second tour des présidentielles
c'est le plus gros enjeu politique pour
les personnes qui sont présentes pour
accéder à la fonction suprême tout est
pensé ne vous dites pas que la position
de l'un ou de l'autre ça veut dire
quelque chose d'hasardeux quand c'est
des choses qui sont tenues qui sont
maintenus c'est que ça a été pensé en
amont n'y a aucun doute à avoir là
dessus c'est comme ça depuis les
anciennes élections on pourrait même
parler des anciennes élections de 74 2
82 90 etc on retrouve en fait à chaque
fois un travail qui a été fait en amont
d'entraînement donc la seule petite
question que je me pose c'est ce que
marine le pen elle s'est fait un faux
départ un petit peu à la mélenchon vous
savez mélenchon il aime bien faire
semblant d fois de ne pas savoir par où
sortir et c'est parce que ça crée du
naturel de la proximité et du sourire
donc est-ce qu'elle l'a fait exprès ou
pas en tout cas elle n'a pas l'air
perturbé par le fait d'avoir commencé en
amont elle a pas l'air du tout
déstabilisé de sa gelée vue souffrir je
les ai vus s'inquiéter je n'ai vu
s'inquiéter d'un déclassement emmanuel
macron commence par avoir la posture du
verrouillage c'est à dire que très
clairement il forme un cadenas avec ses
doigts qui pose sur sa bouche pour déjà
montré qu'il va pas intervenir et pour
s'empêcher lui-même d'intervenir ces
débats-là du second tour en temps normal
on se coupe assez peu alors là on verra
dans la vidéo que parfois il ce couple
parfois ça s'échauffe un petit peu mais
quand même très très peu puisque même un
moment donné eux deux ont dit qu'ils
étaient sages cette fois là je voudrais
lui dire que un autre choix est possible
fondée sur le respect est fondée sur le
bon sens
si le peuple français je m'arrête encore
sur la position d' écoute des manuels
macron parce que on peut quand même là
des tags ils se trouvent comme ça où
comme ça je ne sais pas si si vraiment
c'est la main droite sur la gauche la
gauche sur la droite mais peu importe et
ça encore une fois c'est par hasard
qu'ils pourraient avoir la posture de
l'homme solide qui écoute et qui
froncent pour analyser et en fait il a
décidé d'être celui qui fait aller moi
si je t'écoute
donc il ya un truc entre qui envoie un
message pas vraiment de mépris on
pourrait dire que c'est du mépris mais
si c'était un vrai mépris il aurait des
à 6000 tr sur le visage donc c'est plus
en mode
parle moi je j'ai du boulot en fait tu
fais ta popote mais après moi je vais
voilà je vais recadrer les choses et je
repars tiers donc c'est il ya plus un
truc de j'ai pas envie de perdre trop de
temps donc c'est pas un message très
positif pour la personne en face ça
envoi de la déstabilisation ça envoie
due à l'effet tombe là bas je te
couperai pas ça le mérite même pas et
regarde j'attends que c'est fini voilà
c'est un petit peu le code que ça envoie
qui est je pense un code réfléchi je
serai aussi la présidente du quotidien
de la valeur travail du pouvoir d'achat
de l'école creuset du savoir de la santé
partout pour tous ce qu'on peut
constater la sur les deux pour l'instant
c'est qu'il n'y a pas énormément de
mouvement évidemment marine le pen quand
elle parle elle parle à emmanuel macron
c'est normal c'est un face à face et de
temps en temps elle embrasse du regard
des journalistes bonsoir à tous les deux
bonsoir madame le pen et bonsoir à nos
compatriotes qui nous qu'ils nous
écoutent ce soir et je pense que c'est
un moment important parce que c'est
celui qui permet aussi la clarification
sur nos projets et qui permet de donc
j'ai traversé à la tête de notre pays
par la confiance donnée cette période en
essayant de prendre les bonnes décisions
et je veux continuer de le faire parce
que je crois d'abord que nous devons et
nous pouvons rendre notre pays plus
indépendant et plus fort par son
économie par le travail par la recherche
l'innovation par sa culture alors on
peut remarquer quelque chose dans les
regards des manuels macroule a pour
l'instant sur sur 7 minutes 30 de départ
c'est que marine le pen quand elle
faisait 7 min 30 elle regarder quand
même majoritairement emmanuel macron
dans les yeux emmanuel macron tbi
regarde assez peu la caméra ou des
interlocuteurs dans les parties
introspective c'est à dire quand il
parle du passé ou du bilan et des cas
pris part de solutions ou de projets et
relève les yeux et regarde les
journalistes et marine le pen mais
proportionnellement il regarde très peu
marine le pen dans les yeux pour le
moment alors peut-être il veut donner un
sentiment d'intimité en faisant je me
souviens de ce qui s'est passé mais
c'est ça qu'on va changer peut-être
c'est quelque chose comme ça peut-être
sait pas calculer et dans ces cas-là ça
veut dire que pour l'instant dans le
débat il a l'air sûr de lui mais pas sûr
de la confrontation j'ai un petit 12h10
les moeurs dans le disclaimer vous
rendez bien compte que ce sera ni pro
macron ni pro le pen ni pro quoi que ce
soit ni anti quoi que ce soit hier que
je dis ce que je vois si je vois plus de
trucs sur l'un ou sur l'autre je dirais
plus sur l'un ou sur l'autre mais ça ne
change pas le fond du débat votez bien
qui vous voulez et voter si vous voulez
c'est à dire je veux la bessée sur le
carburant sur le gaz sur l'électricité
sur le fuel ces 12 milliards que je vais
ainsi un rendre aux français mais je
vais aussi leur rende du pouvoir d'achat
par l'intermédiaire de baisse de la
fiscalité
je vais restituer la demi part fiscale
aux veufs et veuves qui ont été privés
marine le pen tout le long du débat elle
va beaucoup faire ça elle va beaucoup
compter ces mesures sur les doigts alors
ces deux choses déjà c'est une manière
de se rassurer de savoir où on en est
donc ça veut dire qu'on est parfois
instable dans ce qu'on va dire ça nous
rassure de compter sur nous mêmes quand
on dit et la deuxième chose c'est que ça
envoie aussi un message positif que ce
soit le cas ou pas c'est ça envoie
toujours un message de j'ai travaillé en
amont et je sais de quoi je parle
puisque je sais combien de mesures il ya
et regardez je vais vous les détailler
et vous savez vous aussi où j'en suis
parce que tout ça c'est pas du vent et
c'est prévu à l'avancé c'est ça que ça
veut dire bon en revers on voit emmanuel
macron toujours en train de se barrer la
bouche pour ne pas réagir et de prendre
ces petites notes ça ça marche pour l'un
comme pour l'autre les débats ça prend
des notes pour pouvoir rebondir par la
suite
madame le pen a raison de dire que les
chiffres en effet qu'ils sont pas les
miens qui sont ceux des organismes
indépendants de l'insee on établisse
très bien que sous ce quinquennat le
pouvoir d'achat en particulier de tous
les français mais des françaises et des
français qui travaillent et qui sont les
classes moyennes et populaires a
augmenté mais les chiffres en moyenne ne
viennent pas aidé à finir le mois quand
la vie devient plus cher comme depuis
plusieurs mois et donc c'est une réalité
et je pars c'est intéressant de voir
l'attitude des côtes de maille mme le
pen à la une écoute beaucoup plus aux
abois aux aguets d'ailleurs que on
comprend à partir de 200 début de phrase
qu' elle ne sait pas où il veut en venir
donc à la le corps légèrement rapprocher
l france légèrement les sous les
sourcils et au moment où il va où il va
dévoiler ce qui veut dire c'est là où
elles circulent et elle prend une note
parce qu'elle vient de comprendre en
fait le système c'est pour ça que lui
s'y poser parce que c'est un petit peu
comme tjrs un peu pour faire référence
celui qui parlait de gérard majax
l'année dans le débat c'est un vieux
magicien c'est une attitude de magicien
c'est à dire que lui il est sûr de lui
parce que il sait qu'il a commencé à
faire quelque chose qui crée du suspense
il sait qu'elle ne sait pas quelle est
la fin de son numéro et donc ils captent
l'attention à ce moment là il va pouvoir
faire un climax un effet fort et donc on
le voit là pour le coup n'est pas en
train de regarder ailleurs il la regarde
bien elle il regarde bien la caméra et
regarde bien les journalistes il sait où
il va et l on voit très clairement que
ce moment réside à la vache ok c'est là
dessus qu'il veut m'emmener j'assume est
ce que je veux maintenir ses face aux
prix de l'énergie tels que madame le pen
l'a décrit le bouclier bouclier ça
si c'était à bloquer les prix sur
l'électricité et le gaz c'est deux fois
plus efficace que la baisse de la tva
est d'ailleurs dans un que je me permets
de dire que les françaises et les
français auront une augmentation de leur
facture de plusieurs dizaines voire
centaines d'euros par mois s'ils vous
deviez être voilà ce qu'on voit sur la
manière de macron c'est que quand il
parle quand il prend la parole il est en
complète opposition avec avec ce qu'il
renvoie comme énergie quand il est en
qualité d'écouté en qualité d écoute un
peu molle comme ça comme ça c'est limite
si dans ma tête je le vois pas décoiffé
en mode raid donc fait pas trop le temps
quand ça lui de prendre la parole il est
un peu trop énergiques pour le coup
d'envoi pas mal d'énergie et il envoie
beaucoup de chiffres on les entend bon
ça on s'en fout c'est du verbal mais
mais des attitudes ou voilà ça regarde
franchement ça parle un peu vite ça à
des tic un petit peu nerveux et puis de
temps en temps ça se tient un petit peu
de menton tout ce qu'il essaie d'envoyer
là c'est l'attitude d'un travailleur en
fait il veut envoyer l'attitude non pas
de quelqu'un qui promet pour le futur
mais de quelqu'un qui est déjà sur le
terrain était déjà en train de bosser ce
que ça envoie comme image c'est avant
j'étais en train de bosser là avant le
débat et après je vais bosser encore on
n'est pas dans le cadre un petit peu
formel qu'incarne la pas pour le coup
marine le pen qui a plus une attitude
d'élections présidentielles tels qu'on
habite l'habitude de voir mais elle
macro est un peu en décalage avec sa
avec cette source d'énergie quand il est
en écoute et sept sur nrj quand il prend
la parole parce que vous avez voté
contre ce bouclier énergétique on se
retrouve avec des chiffres qui sont
problématiques donc la première chose
maintenir ce bouclier aussi longtemps la
crise est là et j'assume totalement que
c'est un dispositif de crise est la
différence avec vous la deuxième c'est
que c'est plus efficace deux fois plus
que vous
là vous l'avez vu c'est quand même très
marquant par rapport à ce que je disais
juste là précédemment i la pointe du
doigt il a pointe du doigt et ce à
partir de ce moment là où il va
commencer à poser les grandes
différences et à dia nous n'avons pas du
tout la même vision là dessus c'est
assez provocateur aussi de pointer du
doigt quelqu'un parce que ses
accusateurs et on voit que là pour le
coup marine le pen ne réagit pas du tout
à ça parce que sur garder votre
programme vos 22 mesures il n'ya même
pas chômage dedans qui est frappant et
pas de problème alors je vous ai une
reconnaissance du travail bien fait pour
les cinq années qui viennent de
s'écouler je vous en remercie mais le
meilleur façon de gagner du pouvoir
d'achat là aussi la tête de marine le
pen est amusante c'est à dire que bon il
peut il continue à s'amuser en fête avec
ses arguments à
faire de ces espèces de sophisme de dire
si vous avez dit ça c'est qu'en fait
vous voulez dire ça donc si vous voulez
dire ça c'est que vous dites que j'ai
bien fait mon travail bon là peu importe
encore une fois les arguments c'est
juste pour pour mettre un petit peu de
contexte sur ce que je vais dire donc il
envoie quelque chose sur lequel elle
pourrait réagir ou peut-être qu'elle
pourra réagir et elle pourrait s'agacer
de ça et on voit qu'elle a son
détachement parce qu'elle sourit et ce
sourire du coup il envoie le de in tu
m'énerves eura pa de deux j'ai bien
compris ce que tu faisais et les
français ont compris ce que tu faisais
donc c'est intéressant de voir par
exemple si on prend en opposition le
débat qu'ils avaient fait tous les deux
en 2010 est que la marine le pen a
beaucoup plus d'assise est beaucoup plus
de force qu'en 2010 est beaucoup plus de
détachement est allé capable en fait ne
pas se laisser avoir par des petites
stratégies comme ça on le voit vraiment
sur son non verbale qu'elle est ok à
accueillir ce genre de petits pics et ce
sourire là c'est pas un sourire
d'amusement dans le mode liesse bien
jouer c'est très drôle c'est un petit
sourire de ces ridicules on le voit
qu'il est un petit peu comme ça presque
compatissant fait en réalité parce
qu'elle a la tête penchée qui est un
signe de compassion est pas quelque
chose de provisoire que vous avez fait
contre tu veux dire provisoire vous avez
en
réalité pardon qui le paye monsieur mac
rend le bouclier ce sont les
contribuables mais quand on appelle ça
jusqu'à verra à chaque fois c'est de
l'aser g magique marine le pen répond
emmanuel macron au sujet du pouvoir
d'achat emmanuel macron du coup essaye
de la déstabiliser il voit que ça
fonctionne pas mais il sait qu'il a les
bons arguments et que le fait qu'elle ne
rebondisse pas c'est un problème là on
le voit clairement sur l'image que
marine le pen qui veut aller au bout de
sa démonstration du couple sort du
regard des manuels macron alors qu'elle
attendait plutôt halal confronte elle
regardait dans les yeux parce que à la
peur de se faire déstabiliser sans aller
au bout de sa démonstration quel trou
importante donc elle elle va ailleurs je
pense qu'elle fait un regard
journalistes et emmanuel macron une
satisfaction complète parce qu'ils
voient que c'est la première fois qu'ils
arrivent à la déstabiliser donc il à son
premier grand sourire et c'est un vrai
sourire on peut le voir sur son visage
on peut le voir au niveau des yeux on
peut le même le voir au niveau de la
bouche des normes et il à son premier
changement de position qui est ce recul
est donc c'est pas un recul et
d'ailleurs y croiser les bras c'est pas
un recul en mode oh là là tu me fais
peur et je me renferme on le voit au
contraire ils ouvrent les épaules et
c'est un recul de satisfaction en mode
alors c'est parti ou c'est pas partie
donc là on en a tous on voit tout sur
cette image
vous gagnez en salaire il se moque des
primes parce qu'il sait que un coup vous
l'aurez la prime et puis peut-être un
coup vous ne l'aurez pas donc on voit
bien que la mesure que je propose
d'augmentation des revenus est quelque
chose qui est capable d'améliorer la vie
quotidienne des fous on n'entend pas les
vous la ministre vous n'administre là
les salaires la mairie mais vous ne
laisserez pas et primes non plus
passionnant mais au moins on l'enlève
j'incite et j'enlève les charges et les
impôts mais ce que ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que j'assume pour le coup
cette mesure à chaque fois qu'il maniait
le maquereau lui explique quelque chose
concernant son programme à lui ou son
programme à elle vous allez voir que
tout au long du débat plus ça va puis se
pose est plus une baisse son intonation
et puis se rapproche au niveau de son
visage et de la table edel c'est quelque
chose de proximité c'est quelque chose
qu'on a vu d'ailleurs tout au long de sa
campagne d'envoyer notion de proximité
et surtout il veut lui envoyer un truc
de vient on oublie le débat je
t'explique qui t'es trompé t'as pas
compris il a un truc un petit peu
professoral un petit peu je t'explique
pourquoi ton fantasme est pas bon c'est
pas dans la réalité moi suis sur le
terrain je suis dans les chiffres donc
laisse moi te raconter le laisse moi
expliquer comment ça se passe donc il en
il envoie ce vrai truc là où où il a
décidé dans son attitude ne pas avoir
encore une fois ce truc agressif mais
plus ce truc devient bien je t'explique
en fait t'es comme s'il avait envie de
l'aider en fait en réalité est là on
voit encore sur le visage de marine le
pen ce sourire de tu meures a pas comme
ça elle est allée pas du tout dupe de
latitude et elle va essayer de pas
rentrer là dedans je voudrais pas que
celles et ceux qui nous écoutent pense
qu'avec vous leur salaire va augmenter
de 10% mais pas automatique pardon mais
je croyais ce que je peux revenir à au
blocage des prix madame le pen est ce
que je suis content d'apprendre vous le
maintenez mais vous avez voté contre
quand il est passé à l'assemblée
pourquoi à ce que je souhaite changer le
système de fond en comble mais parce que
je veux réaliser j'avais voté contre le
blocage des prix parce que je veux
restituer aux français un des prix de
l'énergie qui sont la conséquence de
l'investissement de leur part alors la
marine le pen elle se sentait attaquée
elles se sentent attaqués de manière à
l'été on le voyait aussi corporellement
elle commence à se refermer à refermer
les mains on voyait de la densité
blanche
au niveau de la base des doigts ce qui
veut dire qu'elle serre est un petit peu
et elle cherchait en fait à encaisser
les coups pour pouvoir y répondre d'un
coup derrière et comme nous sommes
interconnecté nous avons besoin du
marché européen simplement il faut c'est
ce que la france a entrepris sous sa
présidence pour ça qu'il faut réformer
l'europe faux pas en sortir eh bien
c'est ce que j'ai lancé il faut pouvoir
justement réforme et l'envoie marine le
pen quand l appel de l as déglutit et
elle a eu un claquement de langue ça
veut dire qu'elle allait répondre à ça
alors peut-être à l'aller dire oui je
veux sortir de l'europe ou non je passe
à faire de l'europe un bordeaux ce
qu'elle allait dire on voit qu'elle
allait dire quelque chose et c'est est
prêt à sortir et donc qu'il ya eu
raisonnement est donc à la ravaler pour
surtout ne pas répondre à ça alors même
que vladimir poutine avait reconnu que
les conditions de ce référendum en
crimée étaient les siennes vous l'avez
fait pourquoi ai je le dis avec beaucoup
de gravité ce soit parce que ça pour
notre pays c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
parce que vous dépendez du pouvoir russe
et que vous dépendez de monsieur poutine
parce que quelques mois après avoir dit
cela madame le pen vous avez contracté
un prêt en 2015 auprès d'une banque
russe alors là je suis obligé de médias
un petit peu le verbale et non verbale
emmanuel macron attaque le sujet de la
russie pour marine le pen elle a pas vu
venir à ce moment précis d'où le
mouvement de recul la bouche qui s'ouvre
le déguisement là elle se reprend l
france pour prendre d'attac et pouvoir
répondre parce que dites vous bien que
les vrais casseroles venir les
casseroles de marine le pen avec la
russie les casseroles de manioc mâcon
avec mckinsey ils sont ils sont
conscients de ça va être abordée et que
ça va ça va s'immiscer dans le débat de
cette soirée là donc c'est presque pas
très utile en fait parce qu'ils sont
préparés complètement à répondre à ça en
fait parce que c'est des casseroles
public c'est des casseroles qu'on
connaît déjà donc oui ça va faire
plaisir aux partisans de l'un ou au
parti de l'autre que ce soit me
sur le devant de la scène mais
évidemment ils sont armés pour se
défendre de ça et pour avoir aussi un
contournement de propos donc l on voit
dans le non verbal et s'est fait
surprendre parce qu'elle s'est dit wow
je pensais pas que ce serait à cet
endroit là qu'il le mettrait sur le
terrain
mais là maintenant aller en position de
jean caisse et je vais être prêtre
puissance à puissance vous ne pouvez pas
défendre correctement sur ce sujet des
intérêts de la france parce que vos
intérêts sont liés à des gens proches du
pouvoir russe avait évidemment le
pouvoir répondre à ce que ça veut dire
mais là on voit dans un mouvement de
recul à emmanuel macron autant tout à
l'heure il avait fait son truc de larges
sourires et comme ça donc c'était la
satisfaction là c'était plutôt un
mouvement de recul droit un mode j'ai
terminé démonstration faite donc là on a
une c'est une auto satisfaction de sa
part d'avoir largué sa bombe et d'avoir
pu la largue exactement comme il avait
prévu de la largue et du pouvoir russe
vous dépendez d'ailleurs emmanuel macron
parce que hélas c'est la première fois
d'ailleurs je crois qu'on voit marine le
pen le faire juste avant de répondre
elle réalise un tout petit peu ses
feuilles ça prend qu'une demi seconde et
c'est ça qui est intéressant c'est elle
a besoin en fait de reprendre un tout
petit peu de confiance pour pouvoir
parler juste avant cac prenant son
premier mot regardez son visage il est
pas comme on l'a vu depuis le départ il
lève le menton et un peu plus d'orgueil
elle est un peu plus droite est allé
prêtes à en découdre en fait elle était
aussi piqué et on le voit même un haut
niveau du regard les lèvres sont passés
la mâchoire est un peu crispé le menton
et relever le dos et plus droit donc
aller piquer en plus dans son orgueil
c'est quelque chose là qu'il m'est très
désagréable alors je vous ai retrouvé un
tweet que j'avais fait le 9 novembre
2014 je soutiens une ukraine libre
qu'ils ne soient soumises ni aux états
unis ni à l'union européenne ni à la
russie voilà ma position c'est la même
c'était bon voila quand je vous disais
que l avait prévu ce genre d'attaqué
elle avait préparé à laver très étrange
d'ailleurs elle avait ce crime sont
propres tweets pour l'imprimé 76ers tête
bon alors en plus de ça ça n'a rien à
voir avec l'analyse mais extrêmement
mauvaise idée pour les détournements
sous forme de même ou autre sur internet
de en plein débat du deuxième tour
prendre un papier le tenir comme ça
c'est sûr que tout le monde va le
détourner loïc quelques exemples s'il te
plait ça c'était pas bien joué ses
communicants ont oublié de lui expliquer
comment fonctionne l internet de ce côté
là c'est un fait c'est faux je vous le
redis je viens de faire et ses défauts
on est tous à vous écouter j'ai pas
ministre des finances l'économie a pas
les bons et en plus personne n'est
jamais intervenu vous le savez très bien
emmanuel macron marine le pen il reste
une question très importante à vous
creuser les importantes que celles là
vous désirez voir d'où on parlait
toujours important madame le pen mais il
y à l'europe parce qu'on a parlé alors
justement si vous le permettez c'est
l'union européenne évidemment puisqu'il
reste très peu très amusante le coup de
brad emmanuel macron parce que là il a
terminé sa démonstration ici il sait
qu'il a été plutôt bon dans cet exercice
là il sait qu'il a mis un petit peu à
mal marine le pen sur cette question
alalala geyster répondu aux attaques en
dix ans est fausse et non c'est faux
donc il est assez content de lui même il
est monté en puissance il sait qu'il l'a
fait monter un petit peu en puissance
donc il termine sa démonstration il
recule il se repose il prend son verre
d'eau ils attaquent une énième réponse
de rebond léa salamé reprend la main
pour dire bah il faut qu'on change de
sujet vous contre attaque l'union
européenne et là aussi comme il sait
qu'il a ses cartouches fait est allez on
y va c'est assez marrant de voir ça le
allez on n'a qu'à faire ça il n'y a pas
de problème là on voit qu'il a gagné
énormément confiance en lui à ce moment
précis marché unique européen parce que
vous pouvez pas dire quand un bulgare
vient travailler en france je n'en veux
pas ou alors je veux qu'ils deviennent
français ou qui paye ses impôts en
france et demandé que nous nos
travailleurs français continuent de
pouvoir aller travailler en allemagne en
belgique ou dans d'autres pays européens
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui vous
avez plein de transfrontalier qui font
ça donc là encore emmanuel macron
reprend cette posture qu'on lui connaît
avec si vous écoutez bien sa prosodie
sert toutes les
toutes les normes de sa voix et de son
par les rythmes hauteur de voix
intonations etc il termine encore par
ses petites démonstrations professional
en baissant de pont et en disant voilà
c'est ça que vous voulez faire comme ça
ils voient aussi
l'attitude en face de la personne qui du
coup est un peu submergé par les notes
et va être obligé de garder l sa
position de stature et donc d'être un
peu plus fort en fait ils passent ils
essaient de passer un peu pour le mixage
un qui connaît votre projet quand on
remet brique à brique les choses en
place c'est un projet qui ne dit pas son
nom mais qui consiste à faire sortir de
lui un homme qui s'appelle l'europe des
nations oui mais enfin si c'est que
l'union européenne vous sortez l'union
européenne mme le pen non mais pardon de
vous le dire on peut augmenter sur la
marche non je n'ai non pas sur la
marchandise tout le monde sait que je
défends l'europe des nations tout le
monde sait qu est ce que je ne veux pas
dans cette union européenne et qu'est ce
que je veux changer et je le ferai je le
ferai avec des alliés alors là je
m'attache juste à 1.1 point qui est
verbal mais parce qu'il est intéressant
dans toute cette confrontation au niveau
de l'europe qu'elle s'étonnant du côté
de marine le pen c'est que emmanuel
macron cherchent à la pousser à lui dire
vous voulez sortir de l'europe à aucun
moment elle dit je veux rester dans
l'europe et à aucun moment elle dit je
veux sortir de l'europe ce qui explique
cette tension qu'on voit sur son visage
parce qu'elle cherche à trouver les bons
arguments parce qu'elle ne veut pas du
tout et là c'est très lisible
prononcé réellement son ambition
vis-à-vis de l'europe parle de l'europe
des nations qui est différente de
l'union européenne et donc elle joue sur
cette ambiguïté là mais concernant
l'union européenne elle ne dit pas c'est
vrai clairement je vais en sortir ou je
veux y rester en enlevant quelques
petites choses cette phrase dans cette
clarté lane n'est pas prononcé et encore
une fois c'est un débat de second tour
ya pas de hasard si elle ne prononce pas
la phrase aussi clairement c'est parce
que elle veut créer cette ambiguïté là
pour le moment
alors peut-être parce qu'elle veut faire
des lymphomes peut-être parce qu'elle
sait pas peut-être parce qu'elle a peur
de perdre une partie de l'électorat mais
le fait est qu elle qu elle garde une
réserve dessus ce qui explique vraiment
cette tension qui est palpable là on le
voit d'ailleurs sur ce visage ou allez
encore droite mais un peu plus avancés
en attaque à ce moment là
vous vous financez peut tout avec votre
fille noire
fille non c'est comme non mais moi je
suis très claire sur les chiffres ma
retraite à 65 ans je rappelle petit
point rappelant la retraite c'est assez
marrant parce que là que de marine le
pen donc elle revient au sujet des
retraites et c est là l a envie de
s'amuser de ça pour ridiculiser un c'est
à dire que en souriant ça lui permet de
le ridiculiser à tort ou à raison et est
du coup bas des vannes ça marche pas
tout seul il faut un public donc on l'a
jamais vu autant essayer de rentrer en
connivence avec les deux journalistes
qui rendent pas dedans donc ça c'est
bien bleu pour le coût de leur part
d'ailleurs j'avais entendu une interview
de léa salamé sur rtl où léa salamé
disait qu'elle allait être le plus plate
possible bien rester neutre et leur
laisser autant la parole et c'est donc
c'est pour ça que personne rentre dans
cet amusement évidemment que les deux
journalistes vont pas faire bonne blague
marine vous êtes climato-sceptiques donc
chaînette oui vous avez dit d'ailleurs
qu'avec là là on a un non verbale vous
avez pas besoin de mots pour décrypter
c'est-à-dire veut climato-sceptiques l'a
pas vu venir je pense que nous aurons
plus tôt l'avait pas vu venir on le voit
on un vrai mouvement de recul est ce le
prends vraiment en mode boîte de fuck
donc après elle va préparer sa punchline
de réponse qui va être le si je me suis
bien à elles veulent traiter de klimato
hypocrite que à ce moment là il a fait
quand même un coup bas c'est-à-dire l'a
pas senti venir pas pu l'anticiper et s
les prix en avril mouvement de recul ce
qu'on fait faut aller plus vite sur nos
projets il faut pouvoir le développer
le seul moyen de répondre au défi
climatique c'est de faire les énergies
renouvelables et du nucléaire il faut
faire les deux simplement faut pas
refaire les erreurs du passé il faut
pouvoir développer des filières
industrielles dans notre pays comme j'ai
commencé à le faire durant l'un comme
l'autre sur la question écologique ont
été
très mauvais dans le langage non verbal
l'un comme l'autre on voyait des
attitudes comme ça d'un oeil qui
n'envoient pas d'émotion particulière
s'est pas concentré comme ils lui ont pu
être sur des sujets qu'ils maîtrisent
c'est pas attaquant envers l'autre parce
que même la cie emmanuel macron il en
train d'attaquer il n'a pas les
attitudes de ça il a le corps ni
rapprocher ni complètement poser marine
le pen c'est pareil en réalité on les a
vus tous les deux sens lisait sur la
question écologique vous avez quoi pour
une fois je donne mon avis je trouve que
même dans le fond du propos sur pas été
bons ils ont été complètement à côté
c'était fou dit pour les deux et je
trouve que ça se retranscrit encore plus
dans le langage non verbal j'étais un
petit peu quand même mon propos la
question s'était clairement comment vous
faites pour les trois prochaines années
en fait comment vous faites pour ces
trois prochaines années et ils ont
encore parler de projet long terme c'est
pour ça que je trouve qu'ils ont été à
côté forme que vous proposez et une
réforme qui consiste à payer les
professeurs en fonction des résultats de
leurs sièges s'est passé mckinsey qui a
proposé ça et je l'attendais celle-là
mais on laisse la magie du temps madame
le laisse
je pense que ça peut être ça peut être
là franchement pour le coup ça peut être
je trouve que c'est profondément injuste
car vous savez très bien que selon
l'endroit où évidemment pour mckidd
c'est un petit peu comme marine le pen
avec la russe emmanuel macron était prêt
pour mac king c'est donc lui il avait
une autre attitude déjà il est en
mouvement donc ça aide beaucoup et il
avait décidé d'être d'adopter l'attitude
du sourire de halal à aller je
l'attendais celle-là et vous avez mis du
temps et c'est assez marrant parce que
il arrive à manipuler du coup par son
attitude est par ces mots le terrain
c'est à dire il veut la forcer à rentrer
dedans alors qu'elle elle voulait
l'envoyer comme un petit pic pour
reprendre son propos en fait sur sur les
enseignants etc lui du cookie qui arrive
et on le voit son sourire il s'en amuse
énormément à dire allez viens viens on
en parle bien je suis prêt on en parle
et elle qui du coup peuvent contourner
la question du pic qu'elle avait lancée
mon mari n'a fait il faut pas dire ça
parce que la voyez là pour le coup il ya
des millions de gens qui nous écoutent
j'ai des millions de gens qui savent que
il y avait carrément dans l'école à
chaque
fois et là on peut voir une grande
sincérité de la part marine le pen sur
ce sujet là dans son attitude qui est
beaucoup plus naturelle d accès des
centres et et qui finit par un tout
petit mouvement demain c'est très rapide
où elle fait donc c'est bon quoi et
c'est pas grandiloquent au sepa sepa
théâtrale comme quand elle bouge et
qu'elle quelques à la scène ces choses
pour le coup c'est plus intéressant
d'avoir ce petit mouvement incontrôlé de
et calmez vous qui montre que là en tout
cas je sais pas s'ils avaient raison ou
à tort mais elle est persuadée d'avoir
seulement raison à ce moment là ce qui
est assez amusant également dans ce
débat c'est que je trouve qu'on a
tendance à oublier que ce sont des
promesses électorales c'est à dire que
un moment donné il ya un espèce de débat
d'enjeux de away mais moi je vais mettre
ça ouais mais moi je vais mettre ça en
plus ah ouais bah moi je vais mettre ça
en plus donc il ya un espèce de truc
comme un truc de poker où on augmente
les mises de tous les côtés rappelons
nous quand même les uns et les autres
que c'est pas parce que ils nous disent
qu'ils vont faire ça qu'ils vont le
faire ça reste de la promesse électorale
il ya un côté un peu enfantillages à
chaque fois qu'ils font de la surenchère
l'un de l'autre et on voit désagréable
la sincérité de ouais mais après moi je
mets de 20 milliards là ouais mais moi
je me sens plus ici assez marrant de
voir que c'est dans ces moments là où ça
perce en fait les les couches et un
petit peu de 2 retenu pour avoir des
trucs sincère où il pense très
sincèrement qu'ils sont en train de
jouer à jeu pousse des curseurs
malheureusement l'histoire nous l'a
démontré maintes et maintes fois c'est
pas aussi simple mais si c'était si
simple d'une bague magique ce serait
déjà fait emmanuel macron entre autres
qui étaient déjà au pouvoir en bien sûr
t puisque le temps qu'on tisse
discipline et qu'il ya cinq ans madame
c'est vrai ou témoin qu'ont vieillir
je crois que ces factures je serai très
respectueux de chacun vous ça ne se voit
moi j'ai peur que ça se vend beaucoup
madame une question
regardez regardez toute cette connivence
regardez toutes allées incroyable cette
connivence est à dire que c'est emmanuel
macron qui amène sur le débat de la
complicité c'est très étonnant c'est pas
un truc qu'on aurait vu en 2017 du coup
marine le pen rentrer dedans par rapport
à la posture qu'elle a choisi pour
aujourd'hui pour se et ils se font des
vannes 2-2 et là on voit marine le pen
qui essaient de cacher son rire en fait
parce que quand on fait ça c'est que
c'est qu'on a un peu honte de rire et
d'une manière générale quand on baisse
la tête c'est plutôt un symbole de honte
donc elle cache un peu son rire même si
elle est rentrée dans cette complicité
l'envoi et madame bacon qui lui est
presqu'en de séduction c'est à dire il
est content d'avoir réussi de l'avoir
menée sur ce terrain là il regarde
justement comment ces vannes ont matché
ou pas très étonnant on n'a pas eu
d'énormes variations et non verbale sur
ce débat sûrement sur les arguments non
plus encore une fois ça c'est pas mon
travail les arguments les pour les
contre pour mâcher encontre machin ça
vous faites en votre âme et conscience
vous avez pas besoin de moi il n'y a pas
eu d'énormes variations quand même non
verbale on voit que l'un comme l'autre
avaient choisi une posture pour ce
départ ils ont plutôt tenu du début à la
fin l'un comme l'autre ils se sont pas
fait surprendre il avait prévu
évidemment des armes contre les
casseroles dont ils ont pas est
énormément déstabiliser non plus bref au
final un débat dans le non verbal assez
pauvre c'est-à-dire des attitudes qui
ont été décidées par l'un et l'autre ont
été maintenus toulon pas de grosse
punchline d'ailleurs là dans le verbal
d'habitude les débats présidentiels de
second tour c'est toujours l'occasion de
faire des grosses punch etc n'a pas eu
d'énormes j'en ai connu des biens plus
belle dans le passé car d'ailleurs si ça
vous intéresse je vais faire une vidéo
là dessus sur la chaîne secondaire je la
mets dans la description ça sort avant
le week-end je vous la sortirait sur les
grosses punchline qui a eu sur les
anciens débat de second tour des
élections présidentielles
mais pour celui ci ça a été un débat un
petit peu sans risque de la part des
deux je sais pas si emmanuel macron
avait la bonne attitude parce que j'ai
regardé un peu ce que votre sentiment
sur les réseaux les yeux français les
bras souvent fermés vous avez souvent
interprété ça comme du mépris je ne suis
pas sûr que c'est ce qu'ils voulaient
envoyer et c'est même sûr que c'est
parce qu'ils voulaient envoyer mais en
tout cas c'est comme ça que beaucoup
l'ont perçu pour marine le pen le fait
qu'elle aime beaucoup d'hésitations ça
fait parti du non verbal ça traduit
toujours un manque de confiance en soi
un des hésitations des études d'ailleurs
du cnrs qui avait démontré que
lorsqu'une personne à des hésitations
mais moins d'intonation sur les deux
premières syllabes de sa phrase et
laisse ses phrases un petit peu en
hauteur en suspens alors c'est perçu
comme des en songe potentiel poule
inverse est perçu comme un gage de
confiance pas dire que ça ne l'est mais
en tout cas c'est comme ça qu'on le
reçoit donc elles parfois elle s'est un
peu planté aussi je trouve dans sa
manière de communiquer ou l envoyer des
signes en fait de non confiance et ça a
été aussi perçu comme ça par certains
d'entre vous voilà ça s'explique parce
que dans la posture qu'elle avait adopté
l utiliser des codes qui sont parfois
traduit comme étant des décotes de bon
sens potentiel merci beaucoup d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo j'espère que ça vous
avouerai intéressés comme d'habitude je
vous rappelle quand même c'était une
analyse qui dans le fond n'engage que
moi sur ces choses là dites moi ce que
vous avez pensé vous dans les
commentaires et encore une fois soyez
respectueux envers les uns des autres je
ne suis pas pour macron je ne suis pas
pour marine le pen je suis la neutralité
absolue quand je regarde ça ça pourrait
être de cueilleurs de pommes qui parlent
de leurs vergers préféré que ça me
ferait la même émotion en fait j'ai trop
concentrée à regarder les trucs juste
pas sur ces personnes là donc évitez
aussi de donner votre avis en tant que
électeurs c'est pas ça qu'on attend dans
les commentaires c'est plus l'analyse
non verbal de ce que vous pensez avoir
perçu prenez soin de vous rendez vous
très bientôt sur la chaîne secondaire
pour voir les punchline des anciens
débat de second tour rendez vous lundi
prochain sur cette chaîne pour la
prochaine vidéo c'est un cabinet
curieuse et n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner ici aussi on est proche des 2
millions à très bientôt ciao